during the last year in the United
States there were approximately 10,000
earthen heart operations performed in
which one or more heart valves were
removed and replaced with an artificial
device and yet the era of prosthetic
heart valves began less than 20 years
ago in 1954 when dr. Charles huffnagle
of Georgetown University introduced a
mechanical device which partially
relieved aortic regurgitation this
prosthesis consisted of a plastic ball
enclosed within a lucite cage which was
designed to be rapidly placed in the
descending thoracic aorta external
fixation rings held this prosthesis in
place although the plastic valve was
extremely noisy thrombogenic and relief
regurgitation from only the lower half
of the body it was a benefit to many
patients and represented the first
attempt at referring cardiac valvular
dysfunction with a mechanical device in
the late 1950s several surgeons
including huffnagle henry bahnson's and
dwight magoons began replacing single
damaged cusps of the aortic valve in
1958 in a two-stage procedure dr.
William H Muller of the University of
Virginia first totally removed in aortic
valve and separately replace each custom
early in 1959 dr. Muller performed the
first successful operation in which the
damaged heart valve was completely
removed and replaced with an artificial
device this tricuspid Teflon prosthetic
heart valve was used for the next
several years by many cardiac surgeons
a later modification by doctors Muller
and James Littlefield added more
circumferential support to this teflon
prosthesis hemodynamically this was a
very acceptable alternate to the natural
aortic valve it was not obstructive was
totally free of embolic difficulties and
was completely silent unfortunately
after 12 to 24 months
these teflon leaflets stiffened and
cracked resulting in recurrent a aortic
stenosis and regurgitation and most of
these leak valves were eventually
replaced with later models of artificial
heart valves the first complete
replacement of the mitral valve was
performed at the National Heart
Institute in 1960 by doctors Andrew G
Morel and Nina Brown walls they employed
an artificial heart valve constructed of
polyurethane foam reinforced with Teflon
fabric the leaflets were controlled by
artificial chordae tendineae which were
brought through the left ventricular
free wall and then adjusted to proper
length and tension laters
dr. moody CCC and dr. morrow developed a
by custom prosthesis made of Teflon
fabric that was successfully implanted
in South Africa these fabric micro
valves suffered the same fate as those
used in the aortic position
it was becoming obvious that any
artificial heart valve using flexible
components was entirely dependent upon
the flex life of the material used and
so attention was redirected to the use
of widget materials early in 1916 both
dr. Dwight - of the Peter bent Brigham
Hospital in Boston and dr. Albert Starr
of the University of Oregon we're
developing artificial heart valves
utilizing the caged ball principle dr.
star successfully implanted such a
prosthesis in September of 1960
since that time rigid materials have
been used in the manufacture of
prosthetic heart valves the only
exception to this was a Teflon coated by
silicon tricuspid prosthetic valve which
was developed by dr. huffnagel in the
late 1960s this valve underwent
extensive and fairly rapid leaflet
damage with large depositions of
thrombus above the leaflets and it's
useless quickly discontinued in 1962 dr.
Hart and outlined the basic design
criteria for the optimal prosthetic
heart valve it should have lasting
physical and geometric features and it
should be capable of permanent fixation
in the normal anatomic site it should be
chemically inert non thrombogenic
harmless to blood elements and it must
not annoy the patient patient annoyance
can refer to many things it's
some noise generated when two rigid
materials strike each other and such
factors as the nuisance of lifelong
anticoagulation it must open and close
promptly during the appropriate phase of
the cardiac cycle and it should offer no
resistance to physiologic flows since
1962 at the clinic of surgery of the
National Heart and Lung Institute the
vast majority of prosthetic heart valves
placed in the aortic or Michael position
have been of the star edwards caged ball
variety before discussing the evolution
of the design of the star Edwards valve
a discussion of its anatomy is necessary
at first glance the mechanics of this
valve seems simple enough but it must be
remembered that there are three distinct
offices which must be considered when
implanting this type of prosthesis the
primary office represents the area of
the inflow orifice at the seat of the
valve the secondary orifice is
encountered when the ball is fully open
and represents the area
Eitan traited comb between the ball and
the valve seat the tertiary office
represents the area between the diameter
of the ball and the surrounding tissue
be it a Horta or ventricular cavity the
next two photographs show examples of
aortic valves in which tertiary orifice
obstruction was present both are viewed
from above through sectioned aorta
the area between the ball in the open
position and the adjoining aortic wall
is too small and a significant
obstruction to forward flow as a third
the first star Edward selves series 1000
for the aortic position and 6000 for the
mitral position were implanted in 1961
the aortic model is recognizable by the
silastic fall and the three metal studs
that project from the valve seat this
early aortic valve had a fumble embolism
rate of about 20% the Michael prosthesis
the 6000 series is recognizable by a
heavy metal base and thick crust this
valve had an incidence of thromboembolic
complications which exceeded 50% the
greatest complication of these early
star Edwards valves was in the silastic
fall this silastic underwent
lipid infiltration which led to changes
in the shape of the ball both the
shrinkage with fall escapes and swelling
with cracking of the ball which led to
improper movement of the ball in the
cage and a predisposition to
thromboembolism or Meishan in 1966 the
1000 and 6000 series were discontinued
the new aortic models 1200 and then 1260
featured new techniques of tearing the
silastic wall and extended the cloth to
cover the inflow orifice
the 1260 aortic model and the 6120 micro
prosthesis which has a greatly reduced
metal base continue in fairly widespread
use these models have a greatly lowered
incidence of thromboembolism and are
very quiet at the National Heart and
Lung Institute we are personally
reluctant to use any silastic fall and
we are apprehensive that the newer
cheering techniques will not eliminate
that only delay lipid and fatty acid
infiltration and eventual deterioration
of the silastic in 1967 there was a
major modification of the star Edwards
prosthesis in an effort to reduce the
incidence of formal embolism a
completely cloth covered cage was
introduced
which utilized a hollow metal ball of
Stella 21 which has the same specific
gravity as floods the cloth-covered
models series 2300 or aortic
implantation and 6300 for the mitral
position had several difficulties tissue
ingrowth
occurred about the primary orifice thus
decreasing the area and establishing
unacceptable gradients across the valve
in actuality this tissue ingrowth at the
valve seat can pile up and cause both
primary and secondary orifice
obstruction tears and fragmentation of
the single layer of cloth cover also
occurred with some frequency the 2300
and 6300 series were modified to the
2310 and 6310 series respectively this
series incorporated a composite seat of
metal studs projecting through the cloth
upon which the ball sees these seams who
have eliminated the problem of tissue
ingrowth
at the primary orifice this series also
introduced a two-ply cloth cover which
has decreased software in certain of the
2310 series a disastrous complication
occurred a close lawrence model was
introduced in 1970 in which the
transverse distance between the prophet
and the case was reduced these valves
impacted in the open
with the acute onset of massive aortic
regurgitation and sudden death this
complication was also seen in the 63 Ken
series of mitral valves this flaw was
quickly eliminated and the present 23
2008 and 63 20 Michael plus disease have
evolved these models are currently in
use in our clinic they feature a metal
pocket the comprise of deceit a wide
distance between cage and pop up which
flares even more near the apex and a to
fly cloth covered concern about the to
fly cloth undergoing wear and
fragmentation has led Edwards laboratory
to introduce a new series twenty four
hundred and sixty four hundred which
features a thin inner metal track which
is the only part of the covered cage
which contacts the ball thus preventing
damage to the cloth cover this model is
in a developmental stage and its major
drawback is an excessive amount of noise
many other caged ball type artificial
heart valves have been and are currently
in use in the United States one of the
most unique of these is the McGovern sue
chalice prosthesis in this valve sharp
metal spikes contained in the seat are
circumferentially impacted into the
aortic annulus
to keep the valve in position this has
the advantage of a shorter operating
time but the disadvantage of a high
incidence of Terra basilar leaks in the
hands of the surgeon who is not
thoroughly experienced improper
implantation techniques it also uses a
sigh last II fall one instance for which
the McGovern prosthesis is particularly
suited is when the aortic annulus is
extremely friable secondary to either
infection for extensive calcific or
Mixel modesty generation in this
situation the McGovern prosthesis can be
wedged into position and secured with
good chances of remaining in place the
smell off cutter caged ball prosthesis
is a double cage of titanium with a
silastic fall this design allows a
smaller ball to be used then as possible
in the star Edwards models since the
ball does not seat on the ring that
passes through it to seat on the cage
underneath the DeBakey caged ball
prosthesis made by surgeon tool features
a pyro light carbon ball
- prosthesis has a cloth covered cage on
metal balls and a plastic cover about
the see another caged ball prosthesis
which is in widespread use is the brown
walled
cutter valve the concept of a cloth
cover for a caged ball prosthesis was
developed by doctors Brown walled and
Mauro in this clinic the rationale was
to eliminate thromboembolic
complications and was suggested to them
by observation of a bend in growth of
tissue which occurred in the early
Muller valves dr. Brown walls
investigative work which demonstrated
the efficacy of the cloth cover in
reducing thromboembolism led both cutter
and Edwards laboratories to use cloth
covering in their caged ball prosthesis
the brown walls cutter valve features a
complete thin fabric cover
which permits an in growth of a very
thin layer of autologous tissue which
does not compromise the diameter of the
inflow orifice a silicon ball is used
when the ventricular cavity is large the
caged ball prosthesis is a satisfactory
valve however when the left ventricular
cavity is small as it usually is in pure
michael stenosis the caged ball is often
not acceptable not only can the ball
obstruct flow out of the left ventricle
as pointed out in the middle diagram but
if the ball is in contact with
ventricular muscle inflow to the left
ventricular cavity can be obstructed it
is also possible for a micro prosthesis
if it is large and placed too high to
impede closing of an aortic prosthesis
in a double valve replacement however
the most common problem with a caged
ball Michael well is simply that the
ventricular cavity is too small to
contain it and a form of tertiary
orifice obstruction occurs in an effort
to solve this problem of size the disc
tight valvular prosthesis was developed
this valve uses a lens shaped puppet
which occupies a much smaller portion of
the ventricular cavity early prototypes
of these valves were developed by dr.
Jerome T of the University of Southern
California in Los Angeles
doctors Crofts and Jones and doctors are
okay and Suzuki Hall of Cleveland dr.
Dwight Horton was also a pioneer in the
development of disc valves as was dr.
Marceau serval of first
there is only a small pressure gradient
between the atrium and ventricle during
diastole and thrombosis has been a great
difficulty in these disc valves efforts
to decrease the amount of experience
metal as seen in the recent case I leave
valve and the recent Parkin valve have
decreased but not eliminated the problem
of Fromm BOCES
another difficulty with disc valves is
muscle in growth from the left ventricle
wall which prevents normal function of
the disc Euskadi have also obstructed
the low-profile valve in an effort to
prevent muscle from the left ventricular
free wall from obstructing the disc a
recent modification of the case I leave
valve has a muscle guard which protects
the disc from this type of obstruction
Edwards laboratory has also made a disk
valve the early model series 6500 used
the semi metal disk which had a very
high incidence of thromboembolism and
this has been modified to the 6520
series thromboembolism with this
prosthesis has been reduced but not
eliminated the Cooley blood well-thought
thesis has also been discontinued
because of an unacceptable incidence of
crumble embolism a very popular mitral
valve prosthesis which is currently in
widespread use is the bell valve
manufactured by Sergio tool this
prosthesis features a Dacron velour
covering initial experience shows a very
low incidence of thromboembolism with
this prosthesis
recently the [ __ ] cutter disc
prosthesis has been introduced in this
valve the disc is smaller than the
internal orifice of the prosthesis and
sits on the upstream retaining struts
this principle allows small amounts of
controlled regurgitation which washes
the disc and minimizes the chances of
discontentment the retaining struts have
no cross members which eliminates a
focus for thrombosis this illustration
demonstrates the potential for improved
all in the Cooley cutter prosthesis one
can see the symmetrical but restricted
flow that occurs when the disc is larger
than the primary orifice on the bottom
is seen the increase in central flow
that is afforded by use of the smaller
disc regardless of the low-profile
principle of disc valves tertiary
orifice obstruction due to small size of
the ventricular cavity can still occur
one other type of artificial heart valve
employs a disk on a pivot which gives
unobstructed central flow an early model
of dis principle was used by Vander's
faith in this cloth covered toilet seat
valve the spring pivot point above the
valve represented an area of stagnant
flow and offered great potential for
thrombus formation the tilting disc
valves which are popular today
all have projecting pivot points with
eccentric openings and areas of
turbulence and stasis the water valve
has recently been taken off the market
because of a high incidence of
thromboembolism the disc in this valve
is fixed and thrombosis occurred at
these fixed points
we are impressed with the Buell Charlie
prosthesis which employs the same basic
principle but in which the selling dish
is not fixed hence it can rotate and is
in that respect
self-cleaning tube your Charlie
prosthesis is our choice in aortic valve
replacement in children or when the
annulus or aortic root are small it is
also quite acceptable for use within an
arterial graft
besides artificial materials there has
been a large amount of time directed at
the use of biological tissues in the
manufacture of prosthetic heart valves
biological valves have been made of
fresh alotta and pericardium and heart
valves from human cadavers and animals
have been employed in most cases late
fibrosis and calcification with
recurrent stenosis and regurgitation
have been the rule an exception to this
has been the Reece Hancock foreseen
xenograft this valve which was designed
by dr. Robert Rees here at the National
Heart and Lung Institute for the micro
or tricuspid position
uses a pig a Orteig valve which is fixed
and sterilized with glutaraldehyde and
mounted on a flexible stent
the valve has a low gradient cannot be
obstructed by the left ventricle in
diastole and requires no anticoagulation
our experience with this prosthesis is
into the fourth year and to date there
have been no instances of
thromboembolism or other sign of valve
failure here at the valve which was
removed at eight months because of a
flow of a slow leak which demonstrates
no sign of deterioration of the tissue
leaflets
these then represent most of the
attempts at artificial construction of
heart valves it is obvious that none of
them can compare with our natural valves
nor have dr. Harkins criteria laid down
in 1962 been met progress in technical
developments and modifications of these
valves will continue and at the next 15
years are as fruitful as the last then
we shall see many more exciting
developments in artificial heart valves
after this motion picture was completed
a historical inaccuracy and a
significant omission were discovered by
the authors in September of 1958 three
months prior to the first day or week
valve replacement by dr. Muller dr. C
Walton Lily hi of the University of
Minnesota successfully replace a cardiac
valve in the normal anatomic position
following an unsuccessful Commissioner
otta me and debridement an aortic valve
was excised and a silastic flap plates
in the subfloor nary position as
depicted above the patient survived for
at least 23 months one other such
procedure was successfully performed by
dr. lily hi the following year we also
failed to mention the silastic butterfly
leaflet prosthetic heart valve
designed by doctors Vincent Cox and
Ronald Daggett of the University of
Wisconsin these valves were implanted
clinically from 1963 to 1965 in both the
aortic and micro position a number of
these valves that were inserted eight to
ten years ago are still folks
well there are useless discontinued
because of an unacceptable incidence of
harm vocês that occurred on the
downstream side of the leaflet at the
area of the hinge site